l tutti i ragazzi sono dei badges e
nessun nuovo bisogno di the forest
allora è dallo scorso episodio serale ho
rotto il telecomando spero di messo a
posto nel mentre che lo metto a posto vi
lascio al video birds allora provare è
un qualche signore infatti james non
farà parte bassa ste cazzate oggi siamo
tornati su the forest ragazzi allora
praticamente successo che eravamo
rimasti che arrivato alla fine del mondo
che stava tipo ii solo che ho fatto due
metri in più perché non è servita a un
cazzo ciao bella bambi cazzo sbagliato
sbagliato studiato volevo prendere
questo come si toglie st bussola de
merda che tanto non accusare ho mai
capito come funziona le bussole anche
sul serio c'è sì ho capito ma non è che
mi serva
c'è giusto perché mi perdono il cortile
di casa mia una bibbia è su cristo ti
comanda fermati to bambi e fatti
uccidere la detto gesù è quindi devi
farti obbedisci obbedisci [ __ ]
buttare ma va be è un maschio e una
femmina ragazzi avete detto che mai un
maschio e una femmina lo so che è un
maschio ma decido io che deve crepare
amiche avete sentito l'urlo da bambina
non può essere maschio è comunque a
parte il fatto che io sono sempre
leggermente cinico gli animali in
generale il suo gioco volevo dirvi che
ho trovato questo accampamento qui non
sono tende degli aborigeni sono tende
umane cioè io posso anche salvare la
partita qua dentro
da questa cosa strana ma che roba come
cazzo è possibile c'è una bibbia
schiacciata dal sasso brutto sasso che
non credi in dio come ti permetti
schiacciando abb vabbè non è ancora ma
quanta roba che facciano i tavolini per
fare i picnic
ma è giusto cioè lanci sono solo gli
aborigeni loro fanno tranquillamente i
picnic giustamente e poi loro si saranno
fatti picnic con le persone ci sarà
mangiati i superstiti comunque ragazzi
nel mio book fantastico che bisogna
trovare i passeggeri dell'aereo non
l'altra parte dell'aereo
avevo sbagliato a leggere la prima volta
come prima cosa nell'episodio di oggi
voglio farmi un arco serio tipo katniss
everdeen voglio cacciare con quello
perché cacciare con con l'ascia diventa
veramente difficile perché gli animali
scappano subito ecco la cosa brutta è
che nel suo gioco qua non ti dicono come
si fanno le cose te lo devi immaginare
tua ecco kraft bonus perfetto quindi me
lo meno dice allora questo questo qui
ancora tutti sti che servono fatto cos'è
sta merda snow shoes delle palette da
neve seriamente ma che cazzo me ne
faccio le palette lane volo fare largo a
farselo mentre un altra roba tipo le
rocce no questo era un fazzoletto ma è
che ne sapevo io mazzi ma dai è su
facciamo un test
io c'ho la bussola nell'altra mano come
cazzo tendo l'arco adesso scusatemi non
devo mai provare ad attaccare degli
esemplari di uccelli talpa che si
infilano nel terreno o quell'altra parte
dell'aereo cazzo per trovata ho trovato
altra parte dell'aereo e laggiù mamafunk
where my soul arco teso bello
complimenti non era troppo preciso a
perché non sole fra agius non so le
frecce allora che cazzo sparo cioè io
non ho fatto le ho fatto l'arco ma non
ho fatto le frecce ovviamente sparo
l'aria sono un genio del male
ok ragazzi adesso cioè cinque frecce
fatemi provare a bechar lui katniss
sarebbe fiera cazzo dopo ragazzotte sega
non me ne frega in questo momento sotto
ho trovato un'altra parte dell'aereo e
voglio vedere quella ho passato quattro
episodi a cercarla non l'ho trovata di
striscio e mo che non la cerco la trovo
subito è ma ovvio che cazzo è c'è c'è un
look i corni e gollum
zio guarda che l'aereo l'ho trovato io e
mio e non mi devi scassare i maroniti
dico subito tanto ciò l'arco che ti
caccio anche la famiglia quindi vedi sta
tranquillo dopo anni passati a cercare
sta roba ce l'ho fatta dio mio
sono due
mica se lo prendevo vivermi sentivate
urlare fino intime cos'è la scheda
grafica nvidia così mi faccio il
computer nuovo e gioco a minecraft
grazie ciao zio non è una bella cera te
lo dico subito i prezzi le cuffie che
faccio anche il gameplay cazzo preso mi
sono visto la razzi lega quella che ciò
che o nell'altra visi tutto in sé
pisodio trovato fantastico d'altro o
l'armatura ai guanti alle mani e cioè
lei palette ai piedi sono un figo anzi
come stai
ecco quali è uscito completamente posso
cecchinare la qua sopra con l'arco
legolas che cosa vedono ai tuoi occhi da
elfo non vedo un cazzo non vedo quindi
fatemi uscito ragazzi gli obiettivi che
devono ancora superare sono quella
allora l'ho trovata la parte dell'aereo
e quindi siamo già a posto perché ci ho
messo quattro episodi per farlo ma ok
gli altri obiettivi sono trovare timi
che sarebbe il bambino quello
dell'inizio e trovare gli altri
passeggeri perché ci sono anche altri
passeggeri c'è scritto qua adesso
siccome sono tipo sherlock holmes e la
parte davanti dell'aereo e quella è la
parte dell'aereo dove sono atterrato io
è quella laggiù dove c'è casa mia
i superstiti devono per forza essere
caduti tra quella parte lì è questa
parte qui quindi si dovrebbero trovare
nel mezzo
sei dei superstiti si trovassero in
questa zona qui dove andrebbero a
rifugiarsi
ma ovviamente nella foresta quindi
ragazzi devo addentrarmi nella foresta
anch'io e trovare i superstiti che la
ricerca abbia inizio mike è figo mi
sembra di essere in un film fa chi è ok
allora come prima cosa
siccome ci siamo appena entrati nella
foresta e non è buona cosa visto che non
ho mai esplorato questo posto in vita
mia
fatemi recuperare vita un attimo allora
ha perciò vi kate e alla pesca pure
questo gli snack fantastico mica ho
recuperato tutto sono [ __ ] genio ciao
zio i servi perché devo fare colazione
domani mattina grazie posso anche
mettermele speculasse io non capisco con
che criterio mi aumenta l'armatura
minchia manco fosse in skyrim che
nessuno vi regalo questo è un mio
souvenir ve lo regala lo zio favi cia
buongiorno hai visto passare qualcuno di
qua sto cercando dei superstiti
richiesto posto con una figata ragazzi
potrei fare tranquillante un picnic sta
calando la nota ragazzo
muovermi a trovare qualcosa mitiche
quanto quanto inquietante una foresta
del genere senza sapere che cosa hai
davanti a dio mio che ero convintissimo
che fosse un forno a microonde non so
perché ma convinto proprio non so se
sono superstiti o se sono aborigeni però
devo controllare maledizione perché
potrebbero essere anche superstiti è noi
col cazzo invece sono aborigeni spegne
frenico che così non mi possono vedere
impossibile a meno che non mi punti la
torcia in faccia non mi potrà mai vedere
testa di merda ma si è scappato
che cazzo fisso se c'è quasi così se ci
sono dei funghi che ci hai paura di
funghi e l'albero col naso me l'ho
dimenticato cialde ma che bel nasino che
ci hai solo porca merda no non ho mai
visto tuo nome visto che uno ma non mi
ha visto non è visto porca [ __ ] ma
visto ciò la luce cazzo
[ __ ] che mira di merda sciocca
[ __ ] da ci credo devi morire e devi
crepare tv uccidere la famiglia
succhiami il pube luca lurido pezzente
no non basta sparare che che sprechi e
prendi lascia prendi lascia è morto è
morto ma mi sa che ha urlato abbastanza
da attirare chiunque quindi via via via
subito
ma chi cazzo mi chiedi spiaggia strana
oddio potrebbero essere anche quali
superstiti mick e sappiate st spiagge
troppo strana non super fatemi scendere
madonna mi ammazzo lo so io che mi
ammazzo lo so non mi sono ammazzato che
culo e così estero e cioè bellissimo con
l'accendino così e geniale e sott'acqua
da cellino dei fuorilegge sei un genio
fa guardalo guardarlo come non dare
l'oscar a una persona così santo iddio
ciao ragazzi sull'isola deserta ancora
con l'accendino funzionante non so come
che tra l'altro è acceso da una vita e
mezza però va bene non c'è nessuno non è
che mi aspettassi di meglio comunque dai
direi che possiamo accamparci qua tanto
ormai o case ovunque io ai ragazzi
vediamo se riesco a fare un falò
grandissimo lo prendo le che lo prendo
fan cuore share quasi
herat ok
brutto strame we bought che è
incredibile non riesco
se ci avessi nelle altre frecce di
uccidere la famiglia quindi ragazzi a
sto punto mangiamo visto che ciò la
colazione vorrei far passare la notte
però non posso dormire e non posso manco
farmi rifugio ma dorme per terra ma
fottitene di avere loft 5 stelle ma chi
cazzo te ne frega prova ragazzi era
addentrarmi un altro po perché magari
gli aborigeni stanno dormendo e se
stanno dormendo riesco a trovare più
robe io devo trovare assolutamente i
superstiti ma proprio di fisso perché
dovunque vado muoio di freddo porca eva
sentite fatemi trovate tronare rifugio
porre di morire se muoio perdo tutto
quello che ho fatto fino ad essere
capiti dovete capire che non posso
credere quello che ho fatto cioè coast e
ciabatte qui che non li ritroverò più
nella vita ma [ __ ] urla di meno
deficiente o cristo e cristo scherzavano
non ho nulla contro la quanto poi via
via vive vivere che via via via via via
via via via via via
ciao ragazzi e che bello facciamo una
partita di calcio siti in tanti e io
corro corro via porca [ __ ] corre
veloce però quindi ragazzi non sono
ancora riuscito a fare un pene in tutto
questo tempo chiuso sempre vito quindi
con questa cosa qui niente ragazzi però
che mi desse da fare se vi sia piaciuto
ci vediamo in un prossimo episodio che
va se siete piaciuti suo commento è un
mi piace anche a pagine di facebook con
interrotto nella descrizione sensi di
schietta e ci vediamo al prossimo video
in cucina a bistecca tu stai da ragazzi